What's up guys we're Pongfinity!
We're kicking off the year with something pretty extreme
A lot of you guys have asked us to play on
a trampoline
so let's jump right into it!
Okay so we've made our own table tennis table
froma wooden board
and of course the Pongfinity net
It actually looks like a table!
Only need the net
Another great use for the pongfinity net!
It's really difficult
You can move really fastfrom corner to corner
Around the net!
I don't know why I did that
I've been jumping for one hour now
Let's go playsome trampoline ping pong
Should be fun
Okay Otto!
It feels quite fun too!
Ah, I need a break
Are you ready Sensei?
I am. Is there any rules?
I feel like I'm going to lose this one
He always says that!
Sensei is gonna lose this one
I'm gonna lose this one
"I think I'm gonna lose this one"
That was just my tactic!
Hand switch
I got it!
Well done!
Nice job
Another great example of
how you can use the Pongfinity net
Go get yours from pongfinity.store
Now Miikka, let's play!
Roller!
Try and get me try and get me!
If not you then your racket!
You ready for this Emil?
I'm ready!
Good match!
Okay okay I see how it is!
Those hits ain't gonna do nothing Miikka!
Just when I said...
That was an incredible save!
Look what are you doing man?
Emil are you okay?
Is he alive?
I need a moment to recover from that
Okay it's time for a foampit dive battle
Lets go!
I have a flashback
I don'tknow what you're talking about
Coming!
And that ball is lost forever
Maybenot the best idea
That was close
Otto, you want a table?
You know, this is my kind of table tennis
I don't mind it either to be honest
Hahahahaa got it!
Footwork wasn'treally on point
Didn't move a muscle
There we go!
That was pretty sick!
You have promisedthe backflip so
I have promised it actually
How is this so difficult?
The hardest shot of my life!
He's going for the big forehand
You had enough fun now?
Miikka is the champion!
I thought you had me there
Yeah I didn't use my
"I think I'm gonna lose this one" -tactic
so I lost that one
Big thanks to Rush Helsinki
for letting us come to film this video
And don't forgetto check out pongfinity.store
Until next time!